hey by the way I've decided my first
real interview that I give about this
new book Howard Stern comes again will
be to Alex Jones what yes yes Alex Jones
put in the request why are you doing
that for Alex JAL I'm gonna do it right
here this morning he's on satellite
prepare to discard your mental blinders
infowars.com Wow in force calm I'll on
with don't degenerate globalist Howard
Stern principal brown controllers
sociopathic and gentle liar constantly
tells people let NAMBLA in your schools
good morning Howard listen hey I never
said let NAMBLA in your schools that's
ridiculous you're making up things but I
decided to give you the first interview
on my book Howard Stern comes again and
by the way this great with the satellite
I can see you absolutely it's a
beautiful studio we have here we are
listener funded we are not Soros funded
like you this is what we have listen I
said I don't want to talk to a globalist
but you know what the Eagle doesn't hunt
the flea you are a fellow author as you
know I wrote 9/11 descent into tyranny
the New World Order's dark plans to turn
earth into a prison planet you want
everybody published it that suit that's
right you know by the way I see many
items on your desk I see I've never
actually seen your studio before you get
a lot of products so those products you
personally use these are products I use
my family uses I endorse these
wholeheartedly Howard infowars.com
prison planet TV you'll get the products
for listen I got you on right tell us
about your piece of propaganda trash
book go ahead come on right well I've
written a new book Howard Stern comes
again oh no a second I'm gonna mock you
with a puppet while you speak read my
book and don't question the government's
accelerated mutagenics program Robin oh
thank you
I didn't know you had a Howard puppet I
do now listen I should sue you because
people think that's really me well I
should sue you for going on about the
standardized total surveillance to
control grid the breakaway civilizations
listen I respect you as a broadcaster
I respect your interviews one of my
favorite interviews you ever did do you
remember this in 1996 you had Hillary
Clinton on your show and you both talked
about being members of the reptilian
elite do you remember that no I don't
actually I wish I would have had her on
I couldn't get her on you don't believe
me here roll the clip
check it out you'll see okay I'm a
reptilian bleeder so am i hey now I'm a
terrible reptile with AIDS I want to
kill and each day team of Navy SEALs are
a lot shorter on k-rock you really have
evolved yes I got to tell you Alex
this is an honor for you because I have
not given any interviews yet on the book
and you're the first one so I did it
because I felt look you're a broadcaster
you've been banned from everywhere you
can't find your show anywhere enlist the
corporate media they strangle free
speech they strangle America the
gatekeepers say read our talking points
will give you administrative control
will they not be one of the proletariat
slaves like Jones but you understand me
and I appreciate that listen Roger
stones coming in the next hour Howard
I'm gonna let you go here plug your
globalist trash book before we go thank
you for that for your audience I think
you guys will really love the book
Howard Stern comes again I hope
everybody buys it and enjoys it
are there any conspiracies in it there
are actually yeah I think Alex will
approve and and you talk about the mass
farming of humanoid tissues the human
and how they kill them on the embryonic
level before they're grown fully I don't
talk about that but I think you can
learn something from the book look
you're a broadcaster I talk about my
methods and the way I broadcast and I
choose my favorite interviews and I show
them there's a very sweet picture of me
on the cover Howard Stern comes again
the Bilderberg meeting what is that was
it taken at the Bilderberg meeting when
you go and you hang out with Bill Gates
you talk about disease X as a matter of
fact that's where we shot the picture
you're right listen you've been a good
guest I tell you what hours
I'm not gonna leave you have to add that
I'm gonna send you home with some
Infowars products cleanser you're gonna
love your 911 puddi puddi with thermal
technology it'll keep you warm
because coziness is an inside job also
you're getting super male shield
vitality it's got some good allergens
got some bad allergens made with red
yeast rice and have entertained you're
gonna have burning urine you're gonna
love it
info wars.com alright well thank you
Alex for allowing me on your show yeah
you want that if you want to be mantra
like Alex all right Alex thank you
[Music]
[Music]
all right thank you